was zählt zum schluss wer sollte das
besser wissen aus menschen die schon 100
jahre leben
100 jahre geschichte das sind
technischer fortschritt und
gesellschaftlicher wandel aber auch
krieg und versöhnung wäre heute 100
jahre alt ist hat all das miterlebt in
diesem buch erzählen hundertjährige
menschen ihre geschichten die autorin
kerstin schweighöfer hat sie
aufgezeichnet
jene von fritz pucher etwa ein typisches
leben geprägt von den totalitären phasen
und politischen wirren in europa
freiheit war das wichtigste weil es eben
den größten teil seines lebens
fritz ist als wehrmachtssoldat als
junger wehrmachtssoldat will kreuz und
quer durch ganz europa geschickt worden
er glaubte dann als der krieg vorbei war
das alles gut sei dass er frei sei und
dann fängt die nächste unfreiheit an
nämlich die des ddr-regimes die
wirkliche freiheit hat er erst mit der
wende kennen gelernt 1989 da war er
schon über 70 jahre alt und deshalb hat
er mir eigentlich deutlich gemachten
klargemacht wie wichtig freiheit ist und
was für ein kostbares gut es ist von
einer freundlicheren seite erlebte die
schweizerin agnes parodie das
weltgeschehen als junge frau zog sie der
liebe wegen in die senegalesische
hauptstadt dakar
heute lebt sie in cannes vor gut zwei
jahren feierte sie dort ihren runden
geburtstag
100 jahre ein magisches alter ein ganzes
jahrhundert lebenserfahrung die frage an
die 100 jährigen liegt darum auf der
hand worauf kommt es im leben an kerstin
schweighöfer hat antworten auf diese
frage gefunden
zentral für sie ohne scheuklappen durchs
leben gehen ganz anders ausleben und in
die welt hinein
er macht viel mehr entdeckungen der
gewinnt auch leichter freunde weil dann
mehr leute kennenlernt und nicht
vorschnelle schlüsse zieht
für den hat das leben viel mehr
überraschungen in petto also und das
alles klingt doch ziemlich nach einem
guten leben also wenn du
unvoreingenommen bist hast du sind die
chancen dass du ein gutes leben lebst
viel größer was für ein gutes leben
nicht fehlen darf ist die liebe die
familie die freunde dazu gehört
allerdings auch der verlust
das hat auch agnes parodie erlebt kurz
vor ihrem 50
hochzeitstag starb ihr mann vor ihren
augen bei einem autounfall
verluste überwinden
das erfordert viel lebensmut das alte
loslassen das neue umarmen lebensmut es
eben ja nicht aufzugeben sondern immer
wieder versuchen das beste daraus zu
machen das sind ja auch so worte die wir
oft ganz leichter hin sagen aber das
beste daraus machen wenn man mal die
negative konnotation vergisst die sich
dran gehängt haben in den letzten jahren
an diese floskel dann erkennt man auch
welche hohe anspruch sich dahinter
verbirgt das beste daraus machen aus
jedem tag aus einem ganzen leben
lebensmut liebe leidenschaft freiheit
offenheit und neugier
das sind die zutaten für ein zufriedenes
leben meint kerstin schweighöfer
zufrieden
wohl gemerkt wer das absolute glück
sucht kann nur enttäuscht werden
für mich war die einsicht neu dass das
wir eigentlich nicht hier sind um dem
glück nach zu schreiben sondern einem
guten leben nach zu streben und das
glück kein dauerzustand ist sondern dass
man sich glücklich preisen kann wenn man
viele kleine glücksmomente im leben hat
die man wie perlen auf einer
perlenschnur auf rein kann
wenn sie diese geballte ladung weisheit
anzapfen wollen wir verlosen dieser
woche 100